bonjour à tous je pense que ça y est
vous m'entendez alors ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on démarre nos travaux
puisque la présidente a juste quelques
secondes au minutes de retard donc je la
remplace temporairement et puis je
reprendrai ma place et bien sûr elle
reprendra la sienne
mes chers collègues nous reprenons donc
ce matin nos travaux pour par une
audition conjointe des représentants du
syndicap professionnel de l'industrie
chimique organique de synthèse et de la
biochimie ou si cause biochimie
organismes qui représente donc les
acteurs de la chimie fine en France nous
recevons donc monsieur Vincent touraille
vous êtes président du cycose par
ailleurs directeur de la transformation
chez euroapi et d'heure mondiale des
principes actifs pharmaceutiques
issus de la récente session d'une finale
de Sanofi vous êtes également
administrateur de France chimie et de la
Société Française de Chimie et membre
également du conseil d'administration de
l'association européen fine chemical
group l'équivalent européen donc du
cycos Monsieur Frédéric gaucher honnête
membre du sicos par ailleurs fondateur
et président de l'entreprise de taille
intermédiaire mines afin élu président
de France chimie fin avril 2023 monsieur
Gildas Barrère vous êtes administrateur
du cycose par ailleurs secrétaire
général du groupe séquence et
vice-président de l'efcg
mais si je vous remercie de vous être
mobilisés pour cette audition ce matin
au Sénat vous représentez un maillon
essentiel de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement du médicament à
savoir l'amant de la filière celui de la
production des substances
pharmaceutiques actives les fameux
Happy's selon une enquête menée par le
lime en 2012-2013 16% des ruptures
d'approvisionnement de médicaments en
France était causés par des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en matière première
vous nous direz donc si ce chiffre qui
n'est pas négligeable et toujours
valable la première étape constitue sans
doute la part la plus difficile à
relocaliser de la chaîne de fabrication
du médicament pour des raisons diverses
principalement économiques liés à la
concurrence des pays à bas coût de main
d'oeuvre et environnementales liés au
défi de l'acceptabilité de
l'installation de site chimiques sur le
territoire alors si de manière générale
la production des médicaments consommés
en France fait majoritairement à
l'étranger ce constat est en effet plus
incontestable encore pour ce qui est des
substances
suivant des données inlassablement
commentées depuis maintenant des années
les pays asiatiques un des Chine en tête
devenus leader en 30 ans concentre 80%
de la production mondiale en volume de
principes actifs inclus dans les
médicaments et 35 % des matières
premières utilisées dans la fabrication
des médicaments en France proviennent
d'Inde de Chine et des États-Unis
délocalisations et concentrations ont
conduit donc à une situation où par
exemple selon le Parlement européen la
Chine et l'Inde fabrique à elle seule
90% de la péninsilline 66% du
paracétamol et 50% de l'ibuprofène
produit dans le monde la moindre
défaillance d'un producteur et dès lors
susceptible d'entraîner des ruptures
d'approvisionnement particulièrement
lorsqu'ils se trouvent en situation de
monopole ou presque dans un de ces pays
toute réflexion sur notre souveraineté
sanitaire et industrielle doit
évidemment partir de ce constat d'autant
que même lorsqu'il existe des sites
français produisant des substances
pharmaceutiques actives il est fréquent
que ceci en réalité
ne mettent pas ton ne met pas en oeuvre
l'ensemble des étapes de la chaîne de
fabrication mais doivent
s'approvisionner en entrant de base voir
en bien intermédiaire hors de l'Union
Européenne donc ces étapes sont
d'ailleurs mal connues elle n'est pas
rare que les plans de gestion des
pénuries des exploitants de spécialités
pharmaceutiques mises sur le marché
français ne remonte pas si loin faisons
de la partie chimique de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement le point aveugle de
la géographie du médicament celui où les
aléas liées à la qualité au climat ou à
l'actualité géopolitique fragilise le
plus la solidité du circuit de
distribution
la chimie fine pharmaceutique
c'est-à-dire l'amende l'industrie du
médicament la toutefois pas disparu de
notre territoire et vous en êtes des
exemples vivants en tant que
représentant de sites français vous
montrer un chemin dans nos avons pu
éprouver l'excellence en visitant
mi-avril les plateformes industrielles
emblématiques de vertolay dans le Puyau
où se trouve la plus grande usine
française d'euro Happy et de Roussillon
en Isère ou doit avoir lieu à partir de
2026 la production
relocalisée de paracétamol sous l'égide
de séquence vous êtes donc les mieux
placés pour nous éclairer très
concrètement sur l'exercice de votre
activité à la place qui est la vôtre
mais connue mais hautement stratégique
dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement du
médicament je vais donc vous céder la
parole pour un bref propos introductif
qui vous donnera l'occasion de nous
présenter vos analyses et
recommandations concernant la prévention
et la gestion des pénuries de
médicaments puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions je précise également que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat elle fera
allongée l'objet d'un compte rendu
publié avant de vous donner la parole je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête est
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13 434 et 434 15 du code pénal je
vous invite donc chacun à votre tour à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure monsieur
touraille monsieur gaucher monsieur
Barrère
je vous remercie et je donne je vous
donne immédiatement la parole
pour parler d'un sujet qui est très
important pour nous les principes actifs
pharmaceutiques le cycose comme vous le
savez le syndicat de l'industrie
chimique organique de synthèse et de la
biochimie il compte environ une
quarantaine de sociétés adhérentes qui
sont des filiales de grands groupes des
des PME ou des entreprises de taille
intermédiaires le secteur de la chimie
fine fournit en intermédiaire et en
matière active de nombreuses industries
dont la pharmacie bien sûr la cosmétique
l'agroalimentaire ou des secteurs de
pointe comme l'électronique le sicos
représente les industriels de la chimie
fine pharmaceutique c'est à ce titre que
nous venons vous voir ce matin en France
et produit à la fois des molécules
intermédiaires et des molécules
principes actifs pour les marchés
du générique ou des molécules innovantes
avec la production d'intermédiaire
principes actifs sur près de 86 la
chimie fait une pharmaceutique en France
est une industrie qui qui est présente
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est assez
réparti sur l'ensemble du territoire
elle compte 10 à 12000 emplois emplois
directs et un chiffre d'affaires global
estimé entre 2 et 2,5 milliards de
d'euros par an
bien avant la crise du covid le Sico
s'était mobilisé engagé pour alerter sur
un certain nombre de de
dysfonctionnements et c'est engagé dans
l'analyse de moyens pour lutter contre
les pénuries renforcement du tissu
industriel en amont de la chaîne de
valeur pharmaceutique afin d'assurer la
souveraineté sanitaire de la France et
de l'Europe tout en maîtrisant
l'empreinte environnementale en mai 2020
le cycos avait déjà formulé 10 mesures
clés pour le secteur de l'industrie de
la chimie fine pharmaceutique qui pour
certaines restent d'actualité et qui
concernaient l'identification des
médicaments critiques le soutien en
développement le financement la
formation le cycose participe au débat
dans le cadre du comité stratégique de
filière chimie matériaux et du comité
stratégique de filière du street de
santé donc nous sommes en Interfilière
représente tant à la fois de France
chimie et de la féfice et nous sommes
très impliqués et pilotes dans le projet
de relocalisation des API j'ai laissé la
parole à mes à mes mes deux
collaborateurs collaborateurs mais de
collègues pour la suite de la
présentation
merci Vincent donc peut-être pour mettre
des choses en perspective avec ce que
Vincent vient de dire
qu'est-ce que la chimie en France
la chimie en France c'est 225 000
emplois dont 70% de cadres de
techniciens et d'agents de maîtrise donc
c'est une industrie à l'emploi hautement
qualifié deuxième chiffre important à
connaître c'est que l'industrie chimique
française en
1990 et mettez à peu près 60 millions de
tonnes d'équivalent de CO2 gaz à effet
de serre aujourd'hui nous sommes à 20
millions de tonnes donc nous sommes le
secteur industriel qui a fait les plus
gros efforts pour réduire ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de tiers et nous
sommes en discussion avec le ministère
pour réduire au moins encore de 40% ses
émissions avant 2030 donc nous sommes le
secteur industriel le plus performant
là-dessus et enfin pour en perspective
avec les chiffres qu'a donné Vincent le
chiffre d'affaires total de l'industrie
de la chimie en France c'est 129
milliards d'euros l'année dernière donc
80 milliards qui ont été exportés donc
nous sommes la première industrie
exportatrice de France alors ce chiffre
mis en parallèle avec le chiffre
d'affaires cité pour les adhérents du
sikos montrent que l'industrie de la
chimie du médicament n'est que quelques
pourcents mais que c'est tout un
écosystème et que cette activité est
totalement dépendante de l'écosystème
chimie vous l'avez rappelé on est
tributaire de ce que font les autres
entreprises de la chimie pour faire nos
principes actifs pharmaceutiques
sur cet aspect nous nous sommes tout à
fait en amont de la chaîne du médicament
donc nous avons des
usines pour fabriquer qui sont des
usines en général polyvalente et vous
avez visité vertolay où vous avez vu les
travaux à Roussillon ce sont des usines
qui coûtent extrêmement cher en
investissements donc nos activités sont
par essence globales nous ne pouvons pas
fabriquer un principe actif juste pour
un marché sinon nous n'arrivons pas à
justifier les investissements colossaux
qui sont à la clé le deuxième élément
qui est important de connaître dans nos
métiers c'est que nous avons besoin d'un
tissu d'entreprise parce que
pardonnez-moi la comparaison vous l'avez
vu la chemise un peu comme la cuisine
vous faites pas cuire une pizza sur un
barbecue et vous faites pas une grillade
dans un four à pizza donc c'est
exactement le même parallèle vous avez
besoin d'une grande diversité
d'équipements et c'est que chacun a des
adhérents du sikos apportent aujourd'hui
et puis nous avons deux business models
le premier concerne tous les médicaments
qui sont sous brevets et là la propriété
intellectuelle de la molécule
appartenant à nos clients nous sommes à
ce qu'on appelle en market poule
c'est-à-dire que nos clients nous
appellent connaissent nos
spécificités industriels et nos
capacités et donc nous confie le projet
ensuite la molécule tombe dans le
domaine public et là nous sommes en
market push puisque l'objectif est
d'avoir le procédé le plus efficient
possible pour alimenter le plus grand
nombre de pharmaciens génériquesurs
possibles alors ce qui est probablement
très important c'est que notre métier
n'est pas inventé des médicaments notre
métier est de trouver les procédés pour
les fabriquer donc toutes les
entreprises de ce métier ont des
activités de R&D très importantes
consiste à développer les procédés pour
faire ces molécules et nous devons
reconnaître que grâce au CIR nous sommes
dans des conditions favorables par
rapport à la concurrence mondiale pour
développer des procédés en revanche sur
le plan industriel on est un petit peu
moins favorisé et là je pense que vous
avez tout le monde entendu tout le monde
vous parlez des prix de l'énergie des
prix de la taxation
des activités en Europe et également de
tout un ensemble de contraintes qui
pèsent lourdement sur nos prix de
revient
je vais juste aussi reprendre un petit
peu la parole avant de passer la parole
à Gildas c'est juste sur les différents
travaux qu'on a mené récemment en on a
on a travaillé dans le cadre du projet
des deux contrats stratégiques de
filière à une étude qui est d'ailleurs a
été versée au débat et sur lequel nous
avons remis une copie qui est une étude
avec PwC piloté par le cycose en
collaboration avec le LEM et le GM avec
le soutien du G5 qui a démontré les
causes de vulnérable vulnérabilité des
chaînes de valeurs sur la partie de
production des API et qui a montré
qu'elles étaient multifactorielles mais
principalement liées à des procédés
complexes qui rendent la production
européenne souvent peu rentable par
rapport à ses concurrents asiatiques à
des contraintes réglementaires
extrêmement élevées à des temps de
développement très longs à des
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
matière première et une demande instable
qui ne donne pas une visibilité souvent
suffisante qui est nécessaire aux
fabricants nous sommes dans la poursuite
de cette première étude à partir d'une
liste fournie par la DGE et la DGS ansm
sur les M6 msis une étude sur 20
substances a été finalisée début 2023
nous vous l'avons également remise elle
est elle n'a pas encore été publiée mais
elle a été donnée à l'ensemble de nos
adhérents et cette étude essaye de
proposer des pistes concrètes pour
sécuriser les chaînes de valeur
correspondantes je voulais simplement
insister sur un point cette cette étude
qui porte sur ces 20 molécules est
importante parce que pour nous le nous
n'avons pas un accès
immédiat aux besoins qui peut y avoir en
principe actif bien immense et notre
travail de trouver quel principe actif
nous devons développer sur les molécules
matures mais mais avoir une liste qui
permet de de passer de 4000 molécules M
iTMA 200-300 molécules sur lesquelles
nous pourrions travailler est un point
qui est quand même assez important pour
nous compte tenu de l'intensité
concurrentielle qui existe sur ces
produits et du long temps de
développement qu'on a sur une molécule
c'est presque trois ans pour développer
une molécule en partant de zéro j'ai
passé la parole à Gildas qui va
compléter les actions du Sico c'est
concernant l'environnement et le
je vais revenir rapidement sur les
critères environnementaux et sociaux
trois aspects à prendre en compte déjà
en termes de cohérence de politique
publique on peut pas demander un acteur
européen d'avoir les meilleurs standards
environnementaux et de protection de ces
salariés mais acheter les principes
actifs à des régions du monde qui les
respectent pas donc ça c'est le premier
élément mais deux éléments qui
concernent plus particulièrement la
partie votre commission d'enquête sur la
pénurie de médicaments c'est que sans
critères environnementaux et sociaux
minimum on n'a pas de pérennité de la
production et donc on crée une
vulnérabilité on l'a vécu dans les
années 2016-2017 avec le programme blue
sky lancé par la Chine qui a revu à la
hausse ces standards environnementaux
d'un coup d'un seul des milliers de
l'usines se sont retrouvées à l'arrêt et
des pénuries ont commencé à émerger donc
finalement regardez et valoriser ces
critères environnementaux et sociaux
c'est assurer une certaine pérennité on
parle et on galvote souvent le mot de
développement durable développement
durable c'est bien la pérennité de la
production de dans le temps et la
sécurité des chaînes d'approvisionnement
et enfin sur cet aspect critères
environnementaux et sociaux un dernier
élément c'est qu'aujourd'hui sur les
principes actifs la plupart de nos
clients ne regardent que le prix et les
clients de nos clients c'est-à-dire
l'État français en l'occurrence ne
regarde aussi souvent que le prix et à
la fin le prix et le facteur déterminant
or les critères environnementaux et
sociaux je les dis ont un impact peuvent
avoir un impact sur la vulnérabilité des
approvisionnements il est peut-être
temps de les valoriser alors juste
valeur et ainsi de favoriser une
production durable au sens propre du
terme c'est à dire qu'il respecte un
certain nombre de standards qui est
assure la pérennité dans le temps donc
ça c'est le premier point sur les
critères environnementaux et sociaux et
le deuxième point comme la très bien
rappelé Frédéric on est dans une
industrie globale et l'ensemble de nos
production s on est là le syndicat de
l'industrie de chimie fine donc on fait
des volumes qui sont plutôt en petite
quantité sur des usines polyvalentes
notre terrain de jeu c'est au minimum
l'Europe et plutôt l'entièreté du monde
donc régler les sujets au niveau
uniquement de la France
et certains débuts mais à la fin il faut
que les lois et les règlements soient
portées au niveau européen déjà parce
que les règles environnementales qui
s'imposent à nous sont européennes mais
aussi parce que notre marché est
européen et on a beaucoup de travaux au
niveau européen dans le cadre de l'efcg
avec notre notamment la promotion d'un
critique
qui pourrait permettre de
d'amener les conditions d'une production
durable de principes actifs en Europe
merci beaucoup
très complet et j'en profite pour vous
transmettre mes excuses et remercier
beaucoup madame la vice-présidente
d'avoir pallier ce retard indépendant de
ma volonté donc merci Alexandra
chewfontain donc je passe ensuite la
parole à Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête pour une
première série de questions
oui merci messieurs donc moi j'ai à peu
près six questions à vous poser
je vais vous en poser une première une
première série sur le prix
je voudrais savoir quel est le
différentiel moyen de prix entre les API
fabriqués en Asie en Europe par rapport
à la France parce qu'il est apparu au
fil de nos auditions que le coût des
principes actifs en fait ne
représentaient qu'une faible part du
prix de revient du produit fini donc
quel est le poids de cette différence
dans le prix fabricant hors taxes du
produit fini ça c'est ma première
question concernant concernant le prix
quels sont en fait
par ailleurs qu'elle évaluation plutôt
faites-vous sur attendez je suis en
train de je voulais vous poser sur le
prix donc je continue sur le prix que
pensez-vous de la de la proposition qui
consiste à corréler les prix à
focalisation des sites de production
après des avec des prix différenciés
vous l'avez un peu un peu dit Monsieur
brin on en avait parlé quand on était
allé sur le site je crois de séquence
c'est finalement effectivement tenir
compte
des critères environnementaux et sociaux
exigeants finalement pour nous c'est
tout à fait positif mais donc comment
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
faire et finalement est-ce que vous
pensez que il pourrait y avoir sur les
boîtes de médicaments en quelque sorte
un label
est-ce que ça serait pertinent un
marquage oui un label signifiant donc
c'est une production européenne voire
encore plus finement que c'est une
production française
ma troisième question toujours sur sur
les prix c'est finalement que valent les
engagements d'achat qui sont censés
offrir des débouchés à long terme à
l'industrie française rel réaliser ou
non délocaliser face à la concurrence
des pays à bas coût je pense
particulièrement effectivement au
paracétamol toujours produit par
séquence quand effectivement il y a eu
cette réimplantation à Roussillon il y a
eu un certain nombre d'engagements
fermes me semble-t-il de la part
notamment de Sanofi évidemment et du PSA
mais qu'en est-il réellement
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à jusqu'à quelle
échéance en fait ces engagements durs
parce que on a un souci lors de nos
auditions c'est-à-dire qui a
effectivement des moyens financiers qui
sont donnés il y a des engagements qui
sont pris mais il peut y avoir un risque
ensuite d'ici deux ans trois ans de
délocalisation à nouveau donc quelle
garantie vous avez parce qu'à partir du
moment où il y a un effort de fait il
faut évidemment s'assurer le marché
alors en France je pense qu'il y a un
facteur qui est très positif donc vous
n'avez pas obligatoirement parler c'est
le volume
mais voilà donc c'est ces trois
questions sur les prix et ensuite je
poserai trois autres questions
merci Madame la rapporteur concernant la
première question différentielle de prix
je pense qu'on va prendre deux exemples
bien connus de mes deux de mes deux
collègues je vais passer la parole à
Frédéric pour ça alors je vais vous
donner
les informations économiques connaissent
concernant une molécule dont vous avez
déjà parlé dans cette commission les
oméprazole ou l'Inexium puisque nous
sommes fabricants des oméprazols et nous
assurons à peu près plus du tiers des
volumes mondiaux dans l'usine de
Dunkerque
alors je me suis intéressé à la question
dans la préparation de cette enquête et
aujourd'hui si vous achetez de les
oméprazole générique
par boîte de 28 comprimés d'osier à 40
mg vous avez un prix avant honoraires de
dispensation de 4,04 €
voilà donc ça vous allez sur le sur
Internet vous trouvez ce prix avant
honoraire de dispensation alors pour
vous ayez à un ordre de grandeur les
oméprazols si vous voulez vous pouvez
payer la recherche si vous voulez payer
les investissements industriels et
continuer à pouvoir financer des
activités de développement de procéder
pour continuer à proposer au marché des
molécules qui sont génériques c'est à
peu près de l'ordre de 340 euros du kilo
alors si vous faites le calcul ça
représente 17 centimes sur les 4,04 que
je vous ai donné donc je pense que nous
sommes qu'un élément économique
de la chaîne totale d'approvisionnement
du médicament et je le rappelle le prix
est avant honoraires de dispensation
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est la
comparaison avec l'Asie et l'Asie vous
allez trouver des prix qui vont jusqu'à
moins de la moitié de ce prix de 340 que
je vous citer
et nous avons même des cas où il existe
des possibilités
d'approvisionner en Asie des
des quatre qualités qui sont égales au
prix des matières premières
donc ce qui veut dire que vous avez dans
la chaîne du médicament
des fabrications à plusieurs vitesses de
qualité et que pour l'apprécier
pleinement c'est ce que gildasiset il y
avait tous les aspects RSE mais il y a
tous les aspects de traçabilité qui sont
aujourd'hui impossibles à gérer donc il
faut savoir qu'il y a une grande
disparité et que là sur cet exemple très
concret vous vous rendez compte des des
enjeux économiques mais encore une fois
pour nous même si on le pouvait on avait
des clients qui vendaient en France
disent ce serait 17 centimes
par boîte faut savoir que nous nous
assurons un tiers de la au moins un
tiers de la demande mondiale ce qui veut
dire qu'il y a beaucoup de clients à
travers le monde qui sont sensibles à
notre qualité au fait qu'on respecte les
enjeux RSE mais que
ceci n'est pas pris en compte au niveau
de l'État français donc aujourd'hui on
peut être en pénurie des oméprazole vous
le trouverez en parapharmacie là vous le
paierez pas 4 0 4 mais 28 ou 30 euros la
boîte mais pour vendre à ce prix là nous
n'avons pas de clients intéressés à le
faire sur le marché français
si vous voulez réagir peut-être
également pour illustrer donc sur nos
métiers comme on l'a dit on fait des
principes actifs pour les métiers
génériques et des principes actifs pour
les métiers innovants en fonction de la
complexité de la synthèse de la molécule
nos gros postes de coûts sont d'abord
bien sûr l'énergie la partie sociale
pour les molécules les plus complexes
puisque on est sur des métiers de chimie
fin qui restent assez manuels et
également les matières premières que
l'on achète et qui sont en général des
matières de commodité qui sont
disponibles sur toute l'Europe mais au
prix européen par rapport au prix
asiatique ou au prix américain donc
aujourd'hui sur la plupart des molécules
ce qui a été vu dans les dans l'étude
PwC c'est qu'on a un différentiel de
compétitivité par rapport à l'Asie de
l'ordre 30 à 40%
sur la plupart des matières actives et
là où on peut gagner en compétitivité
c'est ce qu'a rappelé monsieur gaucher
tout à l'heure c'est le développement
nouveau procédé qui sont plus efficaces
plus performants et sur lesquels on
arrive à valoriser une performance
environnementale et une performance
sociale meilleure et sur les gros
différentiels de compétitivité l'énergie
par rapport à l'Asie commence à en être
un ça en n'était pas aujourd'hui alors
on se parle c'etait les matières
premières qui sont dérivées d’énergie
n'étaient pas un sujet il y a 5 ans
aujourd'hui en devient un et donc
aujourd'hui les facteurs de
compétitivité les plus durables enfin
ceux qui sont historiques et durables
c'est vraiment
l'aspect social et l'aspect
environnemental avec la gestion des
effluents la gestion des COV la gestion
des déchets
et je compléterai enfin pour pour ma
société pour juste vous donner une ordre
d'idée les corticostéroïdes que nous
fabriquons sur le site de Vertolaye sont
également en très fortes concurrence par
rapport à l'Asie avec des différentiels
de prix qui peuvent être du du double ou
quasiment parfois du triple c'est
aggravé par le fait que
les étapes de fabrication sont longues
il y a 30 40 étapes de fabrication et
donc le poids social en même temps que
le poids des investissements et le poids
de du traitement des effluents est un
point qui est extrêmement important et
donc je pense que dans bien des cas le
si nous étions tous je dirais sur les
mêmes critères je pense que les
différences réel serait beaucoup plus
faible parce que nous sommes des
industries performantes
mais dans bien les cas nous sommes
effectivement vraiment je dirais amputés
d'un certain nombre de d'avantages du
fait d'une concurrence qui est souvent
un peu déloyale d'un point de vue et
social et environnemental
peut-être pour répondre à votre question
madame la rapporteur la dernière en tout
cas je pense qu'effectivement l'État et
le donneur d'ordre une fine et donc il
nous paraîtrait essentiel comme à
l'instar de la plupart de nos clients
vous intégriez effectivement les
critères RSE dans la judication des
démarches et surtout je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous nous sommes qu'un
élément de la chaîne d'approvisionnement
donc ça voudrait dire qu'il y aurait des
accords tripartite entre l'État le
pharmacien et le chimiste parce que
sinon rien n'empêche de continuer nos
clients à acheter librement les
principes actifs où là où c'est le moins
cher puisqu'il n'y a pas d'autres
contraintes sur le cahier des charges
je reviens sur votre deuxième question
qui consiste à alors qui consiste à
éventuellement faire figurer sur la
boîte du médicament le le lieu d'origine
c'est une dans le premier 6 c'est une
proposition que nous avions fait qui
n'avait pas été suivi des faits
sa présente des avantages parce que
effectivement expliquer à
aux patients d'où vient le principe
actif ça peut l'intéresser on le fait
bien pour un certain nombre on va
acheter une chaise on regarde un
vêtement on regarde d'où ça vient et
c'est obscur sur les principes actifs je
pense pas que ça soit la panacée
l'option qu'on avait prise et de dire
que c'était ça pouvait être un mécanisme
optionnel pour les pour les fabricants
pour les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
sachant que il faut quand même arriver à
tracer et identifier je pense le d'où
viennent les principes actifs mais il y
a également les excipients il n'y a pas
que les principes actifs il y a
également c'est pour ça que le sujet est
très large et il mérite réflexion je
vais passer la parole par contre agilda
sur la partie engagement et et l'exemple
du paracétamol que valent les
engagements long terme
je passerai la parole je vous remercie
donc que valent les engagements d'achat
long terme sur le projet paracétamol
déjà on a des on a des vrais contrats à
long terme engageant avec Sanofi et UPSA
qui ont souhaité s'engager sur le long
terme avec nous donc
l'ordre de grandeur de l'engagement et
autour de 10 ans on n'a pas le droit de
communiquer sur la durée exacte mais
l'ordre de grandeur est autour de 10 ans
on pourra vous communiquer les
informations à titre confidentiel donc
c'est un vrai engagement long terme pour
pour
ce projet là et ensuite le meilleur
engagement de pérennité c'est de pouvoir
assurer la compétitivité et la
durabilité de l'installation aujourd'hui
grâce à l'innovation de procédé
puisqu'on met en oeuvre un nouveau
procédé de production qui n'est pas le
même que celui qui est fait par nos
concurrents en Inde en Chine et aux
États-Unis on arrive à un niveau de
compétitivité satisfaisant pour nos
clients d'autant plus pour nos clients
qui valorisent l'aspect environnemental
et l'aspect local et UPSA et Sanofi font
partie de ses laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui valorisent
clairement ils sont capables de
valoriser la localisation de la
production et une empreinte carbone
réduite puisque ce projet permet de
réduire les empreintes carbone d'à peu
près 75% sur le principe actif c'est
quelque chose que Sanofi et UPSA
valorise
donc c'est la meilleure garantie
de durabilité de leur engagement c'est
de leur assurer la compétitivité sur le
long terme
ce que je voulais également ajouter sur
ce point-là c'est que nous sommes des
industriels comme le rappeler Frédéric
nos nos
investissements sont très lourds et dès
qu'on a investi sur un site de
production notre but c'est de faire
tourner au maximum nos unités et il y a
peu de chances que quand on a développé
l'investissement est très lourd un
nouveau produit il y a peu de chances
qu'on revienne en arrière et qu'on
arrête de le fabriquer sauf si vraiment
il y a vraiment plus de clients mais
mais notre but et notre marché mondial
c'est si on n'arrive pas à vendre en
Europe on va aux États-Unis où on va
même parfois en Asie et donc ces points
là sont des points qui sont importants
on essaye de fabriquer au maximum la
rentabilité de notre secteur est
vraiment dû à l'occupation maximale de
de des capacités de production que nous
avons
avez-vous d'autres
donc là je vais vous poser deux
questions plus sur la chaîne finalement
de de production
quels sont j'en ai la première question
c'est quels sont les obligations
finalement qui pèsent sur vos adhérents
en matière de signalement des ruptures
et risques de rupture
d'approvisionnement ça c'est ma première
question et ma seconde question quelle
appréciation faites-vous des inspections
qui sont conduites par l'Agence
nationale de sécurité des médicaments en
vue justement de contrôler les bonnes
pratiques de fabrication notamment des
sites de production de matière première
donc c'est les deux questions
concernant
la connaissance de la chaîne de
production
je vais vous répondre sur un point j'ai
plus de 25 ans de d'expérience dans ce
domaine là
nous étions confrontés au début des
années 2000 à une forte délocalisation
vers l'Asie
et le critère principal était un
là on parle d'environnement on parle de
choses comme ça mais c'était la qualité
c'est-à-dire que nous avions des
concurrents asiatiques qui faisaient un
peu ce qu'il voulait d'un point de vue
qualité alors que nous nous étions
contraints par la FDA par la NSM par un
certain nombre de comment dire de
critères extrêmement précis et et très
rigoureux par contre en Asie vous aviez
des gens qui faisaient un peu comme ils
voulaient ils avaient des showrooms il
faisait dans d'autres usines enfin et
le point clé ça a été notamment sur
les parines un problème aux États-Unis
avec de nombreux décès aux États-Unis et
d'un seul coup la FDA qui se rend compte
que les audits qu'il faisait en Asie
n'étaient pas suffisant c'est à dire que
c'est très compliqué on va en Asie on
est avec les gens qui parlent chinois
qui parlent peu ils ont des traducteurs
on vous amène là on vous amène là
c'était très compliqué la FDA c'est dit
à ce moment-là il faut absolument que
j'ai des gens sur place et que
j'investisse massivement le principal
américain était de dire je ne vais pas
faire supporter ça au contribuable et je
vais faire payer l'industrie et donc la
règle des qu'on a appelé des gay DUFA a
été mise en place qui imposait à toute
Société dans le monde qui fabriquait des
principes actifs pour les États-Unis de
d'abord
répertorier son site de payer
annuellement une fille ce qui n'est pas
énorme c'est 50 000 dollars ou autre
chose comme ça mais c'est un paiement
qui stipule que votre site va exporter
vers les États-Unis et d'enregistrer
chacun des produits dans les drogues
masterfly américain en payant chaque
année pour pour pouvoir exporter ça
vient un immense avantage c'est que ça
rendait totalement visible les
différents acteurs qui se trouvaient en
Asie et ce que je peux vous dire pour
avoir étudié ça dans un peu avant les
années 2000 c'est que dans bien des cas
on était confronté sur des produits à
des gens qui faisaient dans l'arrière
cours de leur jardin quasiment et d'un
seul coup le nombre de concurrents que
nous avions dès l'instant où ces règles
ont été mises en place et passer à de
4000 peut-être sociétés on ne s'est
passé à 500 c'est à dire que d'un seul
coup je dirais le la concurrence
professionnalisée en quelque sorte et
comme conséquence ça a eu que de
nombreux
donneurs d'ordre ont décidé de continuer
d'approvisionner en Asie sur des sur des
sociétés mais on fait un backup de
d'approvisionnement en Europe de façon à
avoir une deuxième source qui se
trouvait être européenne parce que le je
dirais les règles les règles qualité
étaient beaucoup plus transparentes et
cette transparence des règles de qualité
a un peu sauvé notre industrie dans les
dans le début des années 2010 puisque
d'un seul coup un certain nombre de
marché sur les molécules matures sont
revenus en Europe principalement du fait
que les critères qualités nous mettaient
au même niveau que nos concurrents
indiens et chinoises qui n'étaient
absolument pas le cas une dizaine
d'années auparavant donc voilà je
faisais juste cette cette petite
histoire et dans les dans les les
inspections je dirais que ça c'est
énormément
professionnalisé
vous savez qu'il y a la reconnaissance
mutuelle l'Europe n'a pas choisi ce
principe dédié du fait avec des payés
par le par le l'industrie en fait mais
nos agences travaillent je dirais
conjointement avec les agences
américaines il y a un certain nombre de
de reconnaissance mutuelle d'audit qui
sont et beaucoup plus de signalements
qui se font dans les
je peux vous dire que chaque fabricant
que nous sommes quand une unité de la
NSM ou de la FDA vient sur nos sites
tout le monde est au garde à vous parce
que c'est un point extrêmement important
et il y a peu de choses qui passent au
travers des mailles du filet donc je
trouve que c'est assez efficace pour le
les obligations sur les adhérents et sur
les ruptures
en fait ça tient en fait à nos
responsables assurances qualité qui
informe la NSM s'il y a un vrai problème
de production mais je ne crois pas que
ça aille au-delà à moins que je on n'est
pas intégré dans dans la chaîne et puis
vous savez que nous venons souvent à des
à des
sous-traitants dit CDMO qui font la
galénique et ensuite il y a le
laboratoire il y a tout le stock qu'on
ne maîtrise pas nous sommes
je l'ai vu pour ma société pendant le
cadre du covid on avait constitué un
stock concernant la morphine au cas où
et c'est vrai qu'il a on a on a beaucoup
beaucoup vendu de morphine à ce moment
là parce qu'il y avait des gros besoins
et on l'avait un peu je dirais anticipé
par nous-mêmes mais il n'y a peu
d'organisation qui concerne la et le
gérer la préparation de de de certaines
éventuelles ruptures ou ou
surconsommation ou la mise en stock de
ce type de produit on est très peu
impliqué dans la chaîne du médicament
aval
pour revenir sur les règles GMP donc les
goûts de manufacturing practice ou les
bonnes pratiques de fabrication en
français on voit que c'est une démarche
qui a visé à aligner les critères
qualités pour s'assurer que les patients
que ce soit aux États-Unis d'abord puis
en Europe et un niveau de qualité
irréprochable sur la substance active
quelque part se pose la question est-ce
qu'on peut étendre c'est que good
manufacture une practice a des critères
absolument essentiels que sont la
sécurité d'approvisionnement la
vulnérabilité de la production voire
même mais là ça peut aller relativement
lent mais voire même des critères
environnementaux des critères sociaux
non pas dans une démarche d'aller
imposer des règles à d'autres pays c'est
pas la vocation de de ses goûts de
manufacture in practice mais à partir du
moment où le critère de sécurité
d'approvisionnement devient pratiquement
aussi important que le critère de
qualité il pourrait être Opport un que
des inspecteurs aillent vérifier que la
production est pérenne et dans la
pérennité figure des critères
environnementaux et sociaux
oui peut-être pour pour compléter ce qui
vient d'être dit
vous avez souligné le rôle de la NSM la
mission de la NSM est effectivement
indispensable elle s'inscrit comme on
vous la rappeler dans un contexte où il
y a eu une rationalisation mondiale des
règles d'assurance qualité il y a très
peu de disparité d'une agence à l'autre
donc il y a une belle homogénéité donc
nous sommes comparables en revanche la
mission de la NSM s'arrête à l'assurance
qualité de la chaîne du médicament elle
n'a pas de mission pour savoir si quels
sont les règles sociales en vigueur chez
le fabricant sont les règles
environnementales quels sont les règles
de recherche pour mettre au point les
molécules qui sont qui sont fabriqués
donc je pense que là dessus on ne peut
pas attribuer à la SM un rôle qu'elle ne
peut avoir et donc je pense que l'effort
doit porter sur la prise remonte
correcte de ces éléments beaucoup de nos
clients le font et ça c'est essentiel je
peux revenir une dernière fois sur
l'exemple de les oméprazole vous
pourriez vous interroger vous l'avez
compris nous sommes plus cher pour quand
on a une telle part de marché parce que
précisément la FDA il y a une dizaine
d'années à arrêter l'usine de notre
concurrent indien en baxy et donc du
jour au lendemain nous avons dû
reprendre la production qui se faisait
en Inde sur des critères d'assurance
qualité je pense que s'il y avait des
critères haute que l'assurance qualité
qui pouvait être intégré nous aurions
une bien meilleure capacité à assurer la
production du médicament et ne perdez
pas de vue que tous nos clients ne sont
jamais mono-sourcés donc pour nous dire
si on crée un risque de rupture c'est
compliqué il y a quelques cas où on est
fabriquant unique mais c'est très très
limité
très bien
une dernière question de enfin une
dernière pour le moment et puis je
passerai la parole à Bruno Belin
oui on a on a donc effectivement
beaucoup parlé des critères sociaux et
environnementaux et on l'avait vu quand
on s'était déplacés sur le site de
cesquin ça avait été l'objet de
nos échanges enfin une partie de l'objet
de nos échanges et on voit bien que
depuis la crise de la covid il y a
effectivement une prise de conscience je
dirais mondiale
de modifier les choix qui ont pu être
fait concernant notamment les
délocalisations donc on reparle beaucoup
d'une relocalisation donc on l'a vu vous
avez donné des exemples et c'est une
c'est une bonne chose et c'est
relocalisations
elles peuvent effectivement être
importante en France mais on sait
pertinemment et là aussi vous l'avez
souligné qu'elle ne peut pas être
l'objectif c'est surtout ne peut pas
être localisé en France serait
complètement absurde et personne n'y
pense donc au moins une relocalisation
on va dire au niveau européenne et plus
large mais en tout cas ce qui nous
intéresse c'est plutôt une
relocalisation au niveau européen et
justement je voudrais vous demander
parce que vous avez vous avez donné des
exemples monsieur gaucher enfin des
chiffres plus exactement en disant que
vous aviez été quand même très
performant par rapport à la réduction
des de l'émission de gaz à effet de
serre puisque c'est 60 millions à 20
millions de tonnes c'est quand même
colossal et justement je voudrais
peut-être avoir un peu plus de
d'éléments sur ces questions là sur
concernant le développement de
technologie dite verte puisque selon une
étude réalisée par le cabinet prices
Cooper la mise à niveau environnementale
et la décarbonisation des procédés de
production engendre des surcoûts de 30%
environ sur les dépenses
d'investissement et d'exploitation pour
les principes actifs produits en Europe
alors est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer
ou pas les chiffres que je vous donne et
en tout cas est-ce que dans ces surcos
vous les avez intégrés effectivement au
niveau des industriels de la chimie
pharmaceutique je vous remercie Bruno
Belin
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur pour votre présentation si j'ai
juste une réaction par rapport tout à
l'heure où j'ai sans doute mal compris
dans les propos de Monsieur gaucher sur
les oméprazols vous avez parlé en fin de
chaîne qu'il était qu'on le pouvait
retrouver en parapharmacie
vous avez raison c'est loméprazole
aujourd'hui mais on trouve dans le monde
les hommeséprazole en parapharmacie
aussi
[Musique]
pas en France
mais pas en France
alors il est en noté
quand vous parlez vous parlez dans votre
micro parce que voilà je mets un petit
peu de vas-y pour une autre tu peux
continuer une incompréhension de ma part
donc mais pardon d'être quasi formel je
pense qu'il est en OTC il y en a un
excellente officine mais il n'est pas en
para et donc il ne se fait pas dans les
prix que vous annoncez ou alors il m'a
échappé quelque chose mais j'ai entendu
28 euros 28 oui c'est ça 22 28 heures au
plus de 20 euros
il s'est passé là enfin pas ma
connaissance
donc Mélanie Vogel
merci beaucoup je vais être très rapide
c'était pour revenir sur ce que vous
avez décrit dans le rôle que vous jouez
ou que vous jouez pas
dans le fait d'avertir quand il y a un
danger sur la disponibilité
d'un médicament qui pourrait avoir comme
source votre votre industrie c'était
juste pour savoir est-ce que malgré le
fait que vous avez pas un rôle officiel
c'est ce que vous nous dites dans
avertir les autorités publiques sur le
fait que
un problème de production dans vos
unités peut amener à une pénurie de
médicaments à la fin est-ce que vous
faites quand même ce monitoring est-ce
que vous savez ce que vous êtes en
capacité vous avez les informations sur
vos unités de production pour dire
attention là ça ce principe actif on en
a un problème et on sait que il va y
avoir un problème à la fin de la chaîne
et le deuxième la deuxième question qui
est simple j'imagine que la réponse est
compliquée est-ce que vous savez nous
donner une idée de
de la du rôle que joue
les dans en moyenne dans la pénurie de
médicaments
votre industrie est-ce que le
ce que vous produisez vous à quel point
ça joue un rôle dans les pénuries en
général est-ce que c'est une toute
petite partie des pénuries qui sont
liées à votre industrie est-ce que c'est
majeur etc merci Corinne Imbert
merci messieurs
j'ai quatre questions assez courtes
mes quatre questions quand même si vous
le permettez d'abord
comment dois traduire concrètement la
prise en compte des critères
environnementaux et sociaux parce qu'on
entend je partage concrètement dans la
vraie vie comment ça doit se concrétiser
quel pays prenne aujourd'hui ces
critères en compte
pourquoi aujourd'hui de façon très
pratique pourquoi aujourd'hui avons-nous
toujours des ruptures
d'approvisionnement de prêt de misone
par exemple
de près de Mison cortancy et compagnie
et que représente dans votre activité la
part de production des médicaments
d'immatures
je vous remercie
voilà je vous passe la parole et puis
peut-être qu'il y aura une autre série
de questions moi j'ai quelques questions
à poser également monsieur touraille oui
merci alors pour reprendre les questions
dans un petit peu dans l'ordre que vous
nous avez donné
en fait
le
monitoring que l'on peut faire
somme dans la chaîne vraiment en amont
de la chaîne il est rare mais vraiment
extrêmement rare qu'on ne soit pas
capable de faire qu'on soit bloqué sur
une fabrication pendant un an deux ans
c'est vraiment des cas extrêmement rares
si ça peut ça peut arriver on l'exclut
pas mais je pense que ça se compte
vraiment sur les doigts de la main
il peut arriver qu'on est
des retards des non-conformités sur
certains médicaments ou dans certains
cas ça a été le cas sur les sartans la
règle des nitrosamines qui s'appliquent
qui impose qu'un certain nombre de de
travaux soient effectués au niveau R&D
et et industriel pour baisser le niveau
de notre amine dans dans toute
l'histoire qu'il y a eu sur les serpents
donc ça peut arriver mais nous sommes
vraiment très en amont et et je dirais
que
bien sûr que nous pouvons être à
l'origine des ruptures mais quand nous
fabriquons je dirais en Europe il est
extrêmement rare que nous engendrions
des ruptures sur les chaînes de
médicaments c'est vraiment extrêmement
rare il n'empêche et je reprends votre
cas sur la par exemple le prénom qui est
un produit que nous fabriquons sur le
site de verte là il peut y avoir des
ruptures c'est pas dû au fait que il y a
une rupture sur le principe actif il y a
toute une chaîne ensuite de sur la nous
fournissons la matière première mais je
dirais que nous sommes voilà les
ruptures qui peut y avoir sur sur ces
produits là sont dus à la galénique sont
dues aux généraux aux clients qu'on peut
avoir mais pas à un manque de de
principe pour autant on est dans des cas
de figure sur ces médicaments on
explique bien dans les études que l'on a
fait on est sur des chaînes extrêmement
longues de fabrication où vous pouvez
avoir de 12 à 18 mois de chaînes de
fabrication donc des écarts très
importants de demandes peuvent entraîner
des des tensions mais mais rarement des
ruptures voilà c'est ce que je voulais
dire sur ce point là
pour
donc le rôle joué par nos industries
dans les pénuries je pense que le LaM
avait fait une étude et avait dit que
15% des pénuries c'est environ un
problème manufacturing donc il existe
des cas où ici ou là nous ne
ce sont pas des pénuries longues dans ce
cas-là ça fait c'est plutôt des tensions
mais fait voilà c'est ce que vous dit et
donc voilà c'était le point voilà
peut-être que Gida tu peux compléter sur
la partie
bien partie alors sur la prise en compte
concrète des enjeux environnementaux et
sociaux qui rejoint un peu votre
question sur le surcoût de ces
environnements alors la première chose
qu'on propose nous c'est d'établir des
standards
puisque dans un impact environnemental
vous allez avoir les émissions de CO2
vous allez avoir la consommation d'eau
vous allez avoir les émissions de COV la
quantité déchets le traitement de ces
déchets la quantité de déchets dangereux
etc etc et à la fin il faut bien établir
une note selon des standards
internationaux aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de standard internationaux donc nous
quand nous devons envoyer des standards
à nos clients
on a des demandes clients par client et
on leur reporte par exemple les
émissions de CO2 en kilo par kilo de
notre produit la consommation d'eau etc
et eux établissent une note et
valorise ainsi une production durable
par rapport à une production qui ne
l'est pas selon leurs critères mais il y
a une urgence à établir des standards
ensuite comment on valorise ces
standards une fois qu'on a des standards
qu'on a quelqu'un qui a une note de 90
et l'autre qui est une note de 80
comment vous valorisez différentiel là
la question est
au surcoût que ça engendre d'atteindre
ces standards mais aussi lié à comment
vous la puissance publique vous
valorisez cette durabilité est-ce que
c'est sur une matière active dont
l'impact sur le prix final sera
relativement faible et vous pouvez la
valoriser très fortement est-ce qu'au
contraire c'est critères
environnementaux ou est-ce que ces
critères environnementaux peuvent avoir
un impact très important sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement dans ce cas là vous
le mettrez plus élevé mais là forcément
ça doit faire partie des missions des
personnes qui fixent le prix des
médicaments c'est pas à nous industries
de valoriser ce qu'on vous apporte en
termes de sécurité d'approvisionnement
durabilité et enfin dernier point sur le
surcoût des technologies vertes
on n'a pas de chiffres donnés ça dépend
des procédés comme je l'ai dit sur le
paracétamol on arrive à ISO
compétitivité avec un soutien de l'État
au CAPEX sans le soutien de l'État à
l'investissement on ne serait pas
isocompétitivité puisqu'on devrait
rentabiliser une grosse partie de
l'investissement sur du temps long donc
ça donne une idée le soutien sur ce
projet étant à peu près 30% à
l'investissement ça donne une idée du
différentiel possible ensuite à isoprodé
ça va dépendre évidemment du coût de
l'énergie verte par rapport au coût de
l'énergie non verte du coup des matières
vertes par rapport au coût des matières
non-verte donc c'est très dépendant
d'une molécule à l'autre et c'est un peu
difficile de de vous donner un chiffre
comme ça le 30% de PwC vient d'une
moyenne d'un certain nombre de principes
actifs et d'un certain nombre de chaînes
de valeurs étudiées malheureusement
notre métier au-delà d'être
très chimifié et encore entre guillemets
un peu artisanal il a aussi une
particularité c'est que les chaînes de
valeur sont très différentes la chaîne
de valeur des antibiotiques avec la
fermentation à une structure de coût qui
est quand même très différente des
installations qui sont sur des usines
dédiées comme le paracétamol l'aspirine
ou l'ibuprofène ou c'est des
installations dédiées qui font qu'un
seul produit et de la majorité des
principes actifs dites
molécule chimiques qui elles sont sur
des usines polyvalentes avec avec
dans ces conditions des enjeux de
compétitivité coûts et des enjeux de
décarbonation très différents par
rapport aux deux autres donc pas de
réponse unique et un ordre de grandeur
autour de 30 % et enfin sur la part
générique
non générique sur nos activités nous à
la fin que le médicament soit s'ouvreuvé
ou pas ce sont les plus ou moins les
mêmes technologies sur des usines
polyvalentes donc ça va dépendre de la
demande des projets donc chaque
industriel a des taux très différents
monsieur
pour compléter ce qui vient d'être dit
d'abord monsieur le sénateur je suis
désolé je suis soumise donc j'ai
confondu parapharmacie médicament vendu
sans prescription et médicaments non
remboursés pardonnez-moi donc là il
s'agissait de médicaments de version non
remboursé donc j'ai appelé par affair
pharmacie désolé donc pour répondre sur
la pour peut-être compléter sur les sur
les investissements puisque moi je
pratique ce métier depuis plus de 30 ans
maintenant ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
nous avons eu une hausse continue des
investissements puisque un chiffre clé
qui est très utilisé quand on fait nos
estimations d'investissement c'est de
prendre le coup d'un appareil par
exemple un réacteur vous en avez vu à
vertolay nombre ou Roussillon et quand
j'ai débuté ma carrière il y a 30 ans
prenait le prix de l'appareil on
multiplié par 3 et on savait ce que
coûtait l'investissement il y a une
quinzaine d'années on multiplié par 5
aujourd'hui on multip lie par plus de 10
alors pourquoi parce que effectivement
et ça c'est plutôt un progrès que nous
soutenons c'est que nous avons travaillé
le confinement nous avons travaillé le
recyclage et nous avons travaillé la
pureté de nos produits
ce qui veut dire que nous avons
considérablement augmenter
l'environnement des équipements
principaux pour arriver à ce résultat
une décomposante qui est importante
c'est que donc nous achetons beaucoup
plus d'équipements nous sommes très
lourds en
coup de en coûts comme je le rappelais
tout à l'heure et aussi en énergie parce
que tout ce qui va concerner le
recyclage et le confinement va être très
consommateur d'énergie et donc
aujourd'hui
il y a deux choses que la Commission
doit prendre en compte pour assurer la
sécurité
d'approvisionnement c'est que tout ce
jour au moment de l'investissement vous
l'avez compris j'ai là ça rappelait
l'effort important qui était fait pour
le paracétamol il faut savoir que la
taxation du carbone aux frontières est
très discriminante pour nous puisque
l'acier l'aluminium ium que nous allons
utiliser le ciment pour construire nos
usines sont taxées nos concurrents qui
fabriquent en dehors l'Union européenne
ne le sont pas
l'énergie si on n'arrive pas à se dire
qu'en France on peut avoir de l'énergie
à 50 ou 55 euros du mégawattheure nous
serons complètement déclassés alors
qu'il faut en consommer de plus en plus
pour faire des produits confinés de
qualité donc ça ce sont des éléments qui
nous préoccupent beaucoup parce que les
décisions d'investissement
sont de moins en moins orbitrés en
faveur de la France et ça c'est un sujet
de préoccupation majeure parce que si on
veut pouvoir apporter une réponse rapide
en cas de de notamment de pandémie il
faut avoir un tissu d'industriel capable
de produire ses principes actifs au pied
levés à vous aviez interrogé le
directeur général Jérôme Salomon qui
avait donné l'exemple du sixatracurium
et qui s'est effélicité et nous aussi de
en quelques semaines d'avoir pu mettre
en place une chaîne mais ça vous pouvez
le faire que s'il reste aujourd'hui des
euros à pays des séquences ou des
minaques qui sont capables de le faire
parce que comme un certain nombre de
personnes que vous avez audité le
premier réflexe d'un État souverain
quand il y a une difficulté c'est de
fermer ses frontières pour garder la
ressource pour sa nation
et aujourd'hui on est mal préparé
présidente oui merci Monsieur pour vos
réponses néanmoins je vais revenir sur
deux points alors j'ai peut-être mal
entendu mais est-ce que vous avez
répondu à la question quel pays prenne
en compte ces critères notamment
environnementaux et sociaux voilà s'il
vous plaît et puis je reviens parce que
j'ai besoin de comprendre un peu mieux
sur l'exemple du printemps donc vous me
dites que
vos sites produisent du prednisone et
que la chaîne de fabrication du
médicament est longue
ce que j'entends évidemment pour autant
alors pouvez-vous nous dire combien de
laboratoires fabriquent des spécialités
à base de précision parce que si vous
vous êtes capable de produire le
principe actif
évidemment plus il y a moins il y a
d'acteurs capables de qui fabrique
aujourd'hui cette spécialité plus tout
incident sur la chaîne de fabrication où
on approvisionnement ne serait-ce que
d'emballage d'aluminium etc va impacter
effectivement il va va contribuer à ces
rupture d'approvisionnement parce que
une fois qu'on a le principe actif j'ai
du mal à croire quand même que sur
différentes chaînes de fabrication de la
spécialité on est les mêmes problèmes
partout or sa fille bientôt deux ans et
demi qu'on a des problèmes
d'approvisionnement dans ce médicament
donc si vous vous êtes capable de
fabriquer le principe actif à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qui va pas
peut-être que évidemment c'est pas de
votre vous y êtes pour rien quelque part
mais j'aimerais bien quand même
comprendre comment ça cette housse à
dysfonctionne au-delà de la simple
approvisionnement en aluminium outre
tout le monde
et et concerné ce que j'entends aussi
mais du coup on voit bien que dans ces
cas là on est un peu impuissant parce
qu'on va ramener les principes actifs et
pour autant d'un taux de problèmes on a
d'autres problèmes pour la fabrication
de la spécialité avant qu'elle soit
évidemment distribuée
et puis je voulais vous poser une
dernière question et je m'en arrêterai
là
quels sont vos rapports avec le CEPS
parce qu'évidemment quand je vous pose
la question comment valoriser
les critères environnementaux et sociaux
évidemment on en vient la valorisation
concrète du prix d'accord vous avez fait
vous l'avez dit en 2020 des propositions
vous avez contribué à élaborer des
propositions mais aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas obligé de comment quels sont
vos liens avec le CEPS comment un moment
donné j'imagine que vous avez des
discussions ce que vous nous dites
devant la commission d'enquête j'imagine
que vous l'avez dit à d'autres peut-être
même au ministère que peut-être même au
directeur de la CNAM je ne sais pas mais
comment à un moment donné vous influez
pour faire reconnaître vos difficultés à
la fois matière énergétique en matière
de tout ce qui est taxé à l'entrée dans
notre pays pour construire vos usines et
cette attente que vous avez et que je
pense nous sommes un certain nombre à
partager de valorisation de ces critères
dans le prix final du médicament et
notre système fait qu'à un moment donné
le prix on le regarde quand même y
compris commission des affaires sociales
lors de l'examen du PLFSS
je vais compléter par mes questions
je vais compléter par mes questions je
vous remercie pour parce que pour
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
Corinne Imbert on a visité donc heureux
Happy et
on nous a dit finalement le plan de
charge était pas maximal sur les
corticostéroïdes ça fait quand même à
peu près une dizaine d'années que pour
l'épisode de bronchiolyte hivernale on a
plus de corticoïdes en gouttes pour les
nourrissons quasiment au bout de 15
jours quoi et que donc c'est à chaque
fois le même discours dans les médias et
donc on voudrait comprendre
parce que ça a été une découverte
finalement on a découvert que les
corticosterroïdes pour étaient fabriqués
en France pour une part alors que depuis
des années on nous parle de pénurie de
corticoïdes et donc comment expliquer
vous ce hiatus puisque voilà on nous dit
c'est toujours c'est fabriqué ailleurs
là en l'occurrence c'est pas fabriqué
ailleurs et on a quand même le même
problème donc on voudrait comprendre
qu'est-ce qui qui explique c'est cette
pénurie moi j'ai une deuxième question
vous avez dit passer de la liste des
4000 MITM à 200 à 300 molécules
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par molécule
voilà parce que il y a l'API ou la fée
Ford justement il y a les exceptions
après la forme galénique qui intervient
quand même dans la disponibilité la
dispensation
et donc c'est quoi 200 à 300 molécules
pour vous qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
ça signifie parce que si on est en
manque d'exception évidemment
l'API seul ne suffira pas je continue
encore deux trois questions
donc la question sur le CEPS
je la reprends également à mon compte
qui vient de poser Corinne Imbert parce
que c'est un vrai sujet cette histoire
du prix du du médicament suivant notre
interlocuteur et quelque chose de
présenter comme étant un peu un chiffon
rouge vis-à-vis de la France
et donc
la question que je souhaiterais poser
c'est comment comment croyez-vous
un critère qui serait de comment dire de
différenciation positive employer un peu
les euphémismes
de différenciation positive vis-à-vis de
ce qui est produit en France en sachant
que d'après ce que j'ai compris vous
pouvez produire des API mais derrière la
suite de la chaîne de valeur se déroule
pas forcément en France ou en Europe tu
restes et que donc finalement quelque
part c'est un sujet c'est quoi le made
in France ou le made in Europe sur le
médicament et à quel moment le critère
appelle d'offres qui accompagnerait
positivement une production qui serait à
valoriser parce que plus local
comment prendre ça comment on prendrait
ce critère là en compte et puis ma
dernière question pose sur la NSM et ces
fameux dossiers il semblerait qu'il y
ait un dossier par agence est-ce que
vous verrez un dossier par agence et
donc par pays est-ce que vous verriez
d'un bon œil qui est un dossier un peu
unique européen qui interviendrait
puisque j'imagine que c'est comme pour
tous les métiers toutes les professions
plus on passe de temps administratif moi
on passe de temps être opérationnel je
vous remercie
je vous remercie de ces questions pour
pour
sur le cap précis de la prévision de
décorticostéroïdes effectivement nos
unités ne tourne pas
au maximum de leurs capacités pour
autant il y a souvent des ruptures
dans l'étude que nous avons faites sur
les M6 certains des produits étaient
décorticostéroïdes et on a fait l'étude
dessus le la problématique n'était pas
le principe actif un peu comme vous
l'avez vous l'avez démontré dans
j'ai visionné certains de vos auditions
sur l'amoxicilline c'est c'est pas un
problème de principe actif s'il y a pas
de principe actif si ce n'est pas
fabriqué en Europe ça crée souvent des
grosses difficultés et dans certains cas
le fait de fabriquer le principe actif
en Europe en avoir même à disposition ne
règle pas les problèmes de tension qui
peut y avoir sur un certain nombre de
produits c'est l'aval du principe actif
qui qui peut poser et quand vous vous me
demandez les MITM les molécules
j'entends par molécules les principes
actifs c'est donc qui donne plusieurs
spécialités qui ont qui ont mais il faut
bien savoir que vous avez des
particularités dans la fabrication des
principes actifs on parle des
cytotoxiques il faut des unités
totalement spécifiques on ne mélange pas
des corticostéroïdes dans des usines de
fabrication avec d'autres
fabrications puisque la FDA ou les
règles de qualité l'interdisent on a
quand même beaucoup de contraintes de ce
type de la même façon des antibiotiques
qui sont fabriqués dans un atelier on ne
peut pas fabriquer à côté des
antibiotiques d'autres produits parce
que le risque même si nous ont
extrêmement attention à tout ce qui peut
être contamination croisée etc les
règles de GMP interdit un certain nombre
de choses de façon à assurer gérer la
sécurité maximale donc voilà donc dans
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que les
molécules dont nous parlons sont des
principes actifs qui qui sont ensuite
vendus
en Europe ou pas dans certains cas je
peux vous dire que nous ne vendons pas
en Europe nous vendons en Asie des
corticostéroïdes nous vendons aux
États-Unis il y a peu de ventes
européennes et les comment dire les
produits européens proviennent en termes
de principe actifs d'Asie et sont et la
galinique est faite en Europe c'est
vraiment un problème voilà à considérer
alors
autre question alors le CEPS on ne
participe très peu au CEPS depuis je
dirais un an ou deux oui oui nous avons
été intégrés dans un certain nombre de
réflexions et notamment nous travaillons
actuellement sur le plan hivernal avec
la NSM sur un certain nombre de de ces
sujets là mais en tant que fabricant de
principes actifs notre avis n'est pas
demandé je dirais et encore une fois
c'est un des points clés je reviendrai
sur ces quatre conclusions qu'on peut
avoir
sur les produits
la répartition de la valeur sur un
médicament elle va rarement côté
fabricant de principes actifs nous
sommes des gens qui voilà on fabrique
les produits le prix est le prix qu'on
nous demande mais on n'intervient un peu
on a peu d'influence sur ce qui se passe
après sur le ce qu'on sait et ce qu'on a
pu constater dans l'étude que vous avez
pu voir de PwC si que si le prix est
très très bas ça limite le nombre
d'acteurs qui veut travailler acheter le
principe actif pour pour la spécialité
c'est en limite le nombre ça limite les
investissements de nos clients pour
fabriquer plus ou moins de de produits
en galénique et que ça a forcément une
influence le prix du médicament quand il
est trop bas a forcément une influence
sur les ventes que l'on peut faire
au niveau notamment au niveau français
après nous sommes très très peu
impliqués dans la chaîne qui suit ça il
faut demander aux acteurs que quels sont
les les adhérents du lait ou du CDMO
France qui font la galinique et autres
nous nous vendons le principe actif ce
que ce que l'on peut constater que c'est
souvent on vend plus facilement en
Canada aux États-Unis ou même en Chine
que parfois en Europe voilà c'est un
point sur le la suite de voilà de la
chaîne de valeur peut-être oui dire
quelque chose alors pour répondre à
votre question on a pas notre
connaissance des pays qui ont mis en
place des standards environnementaux et
sociaux et qui valorise cela en revanche
nous on n'est pas en contact directement
avec la commande publique et on a de
plus en plus de clients qui sont les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui
valorisent ces critères donc quelque
part ils doivent le valoriser d'une
manière ou d'une autre soit parce qu'ils
améliorent leur sécurité
d'approvisionnement ils améliorent leur
image ils répondent à des appels
d'offres publiques donc on n'est pas en
direct mais nos clients le valorisent et
nos clients partout dans le monde donc
les Français sont plutôt très avancés je
parlais tout à l'heure de Sanofi et UPSA
qui le valorise clairement mais
des Américains commencent à le valoriser
également donc quelque part c'est
peut-être le moment de le mettre dans
les commandes publiques puisque nos
clients s'y préparent donc ça c'est pour
répondre à cette question sur la partie
le critère de différenciation qui
rejoint un peu cette question
oui une production moins carbonée en
France et réel puisque on consomme pas
mal d'électricité et aujourd'hui aux
États-Unis en Asie et notamment en Inde
et en Chine l'énergie primaire c'est le
charbon essentiellement et le gaz aux
États-Unis donc on a un vrai avantage
sur le poids carbone de nos principes
actifs donc ça c'est un vrai avantage
compétitif pour parler de facteurs
différenciants
également sur la partie procédé et
innovation procédés monsieur gaucher l'a
rappelé on a une innovation forte nos
trois groupes ont une R&D relativement
plus forte que nos
qu'il soit européen ou hors d'Europe
déjà parce que on a une recherche dans
la chimie qui est assez dynamique et on
est capable d'innover sur des procédés
moins impactants et donc d'aller
chercher des critères de différenciation
par l'innovation donc ça c'est vraiment
un deuxième critère différenciant et
enfin le troisième critère différenciant
c'est oui une localisation en Europe
permet d'avoir des chaînes plus courtes
et donc d'éviter les pénuries ou alors
d'imposer une diversification des
sources non pas une diversification des
entreprises mais vraiment une
diversification des zones géographiques
pendant la crise covid on voyait des
certains de nos clients qui avaient
pourtant fait le choix et la plupart
l'ont fait Frédéric l'a rappelé le choix
de diversifier leurs fournisseurs mais
si tous les fournisseurs sont dans la
même région du monde
ça apporte pas une vraie différenciation
une vraie diversification pardon donc je
pense imposer des critères de vrais
diversification et non pas uniquement de
diversification d'entité légale peut
être un critère différenciant voilà pour
les trois critères que je voyais
monsieur
oui alors pour pour compléter je
voudrais quand même dire que les
États-Unis sont quand même en train de
prendre en compte avant tout le monde
ces aspects d'impact sur l'environnement
je vous refais pas le coup de Lyra mais
c'est une réalité et nous avons
nous-mêmes des usines aux États-Unis et
nous pouvons constater l'impact de de
cette réglementation mise en place sous
l'administration Biden il faut rappeler
aussi que les États-Unis ont été très en
avance sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement puisqu'ils ont mis
en place une loi qui force les
pharmaciens à assurer la diversification
de leur approvisionnement pour garantir
la continuité donc je pense qu'il y a
déjà des références dans le monde alors
il y a une dernière question donc que
vous avez posé et qui pour notre
industrie et est en partie répandue
puisque nous avons à l'échelle
européenne une arme une harmonisation
qui a été faite pour le dépôt des
dossiers pour la partie principale actif
puisque c'est ce qu'on appelle pour les
pour les dans notre jargon les DMF pour
les molécules sous brevet enfin les
principes actifs sous brevets par donner
le jargon de chimiste et pour celles qui
ne sont pas sous brevets c'est le CEP et
quand vous avez un cep pour un principe
actif générique tous les pays de
l'Europe le reconnaissent donc ça ça
existe et il faut savoir que et c'est la
partie confidentielle de ces DMF ou CEP
les étapes clés de la synthèse du
principe actif sont décrits
donc vous avez une référence si vous
voulez dire que le principe actif a été
fait dans l'Union européenne vous pouvez
tout simplement prendre comme critères
ce sont les étapes qui sont enregistrés
dans le DMF ou le CEP donc on a déjà
tous les outils la vraie difficulté sur
la sécurité de l'approvisionnement des
principes actifs génériques vient de
l'évolution de cette réglementation et
on l'a bien expliqué il y a eu 20 ans à
transfert massif de la fabrication des
principes actifs vers
l'Inde et la Chine et à cette époque là
c'était très facile de déposer un
dossier depuis il y a eu tout ce que la
pharmacovigilance a montré comme
essentiel pour assurer la qualité des
médicaments et on peut considérer qu'au
niveau du chimiste le dépôt d'un d'un
dossier c'est 2 à 3 millions d'euros et
vous vous battez avec des indiens ou des
Chinois qui ont déposé leurs dossier il
y a pour lequel il y a aucune obligation
de mise à niveau selon les critères
nouveaux et donc ça c'est une vraie
barrière pour l'ensemble de l'industrie
européenne à mettre sur le marché des
dossiers de principe actifs génériques
surtout dans la liste des médicaments
essentiels et le paracétamol est encore
une fois un très bel exemple
je vais juste compléter les les propos
de Frédéric concernant les CEP c'est
certificats européens à la pharmacopée
pour vous dire que on entend que
fabricant le moindre changement de pompe
de réacteurs de quoi que ce soit dans le
process de fabrication vous savez le
principe pharmaceutique c'est de dire
quand le procéder a été établi on ne
change rien pas une virgule le moindre
la moindre modification qu'on peut faire
sur l'analyse sur le le matériel est
envoyé à la NSM ou à l'EMA ce qui est
donc il y a énormément de documents qui
sont envoyés ce qui est regrettable et
ce qui va se faire c'est que rien n'est
numérisé c'est à dire que vous voulez
avoir un accès à une molécule sur un
site donné vous avez des dossiers papier
partout les gens peuvent retrouver
absolument tout le jour où le ma sera
capable d'un point de vue inspiré
digital de retrouver quels sont les
fabricants parce que comme le souligner
Frédéric toute la chaîne dès que vous
êtes dans la fenêtre ce qu'on appelle la
fenêtre JMP tout est enregistré tout
produit qui a un cep ou un DMF vous avez
l'ensemble des fabricants vous avez
l'ensemble des des sociétés qui
fournissent on
stipule quelles sont les les
fournisseurs de matières premières donc
vous avez à tout l'ensemble de je dirais
de la de la fabrication
tout ça est enregistré le seul problème
c'est que comme c'est sur des documents
papier il y a peu d'accès et on reste
quand même assez aveugle sur parce que
on réclame toujours en tant que
fabricant européen que il y ait au moins
un fabricant de tels substances qui
puissent être
considéré qu'il y a un volume minimal au
niveau européen c'est sur une substance
qui soit donnée à l'un des fabricants
mais tout ça n'est absolument pas
gérable pour l'instant parce que
tout doit se faire d'un point de vue
extrêmement manuel alors que quand on
aura une vision beaucoup plus digitale
de l'ensemble de je dirais du marché ça
sera beaucoup plus simple
du coup ça me fait rebondir sur sur des
questions il y a plusieurs choses que
effectivement pareil quand on était on a
été sur le site de C15 c'était les mêmes
propos qui étaient qui étaient tenus le
fait de dire qu'en gros vos
usines ne tendent pas à plein vous
pourriez produire plus donc on est un
peu comment dirais-je étonné puisque sur
des produits qui vivent des tensions
des tensions voir des ruptures il y
aurait possibilité de les fabriquer en
réalité ou en tout cas dans fabriquer
plus donc comment ça c'est ma première
question comment vous vous expliquez
cela est-ce que c'est parce que vous ne
pouvez pas produire plus parce que vous
n'avez pas l'assurance de du marché donc
du coup vous êtes prudent ce qu'on peut
ce qu'on peut entendre ça c'est ma
première question deuxième question
quand on est allé notamment à Lyon sur
la ça s'appelle pas la Pharmacie
centrale je me souviens plus
ce que nous a dit le le pharmacien qui
nous a qui nous a reçu c'est de dire que
quand un
laboratoire ne veut plus produire tel ou
tel médicament que le que ils veulent
bien le reprendre en fait ils n'ont pas
la recette de fabrication et que la
recette de fabrication elle est top
secrète et ça c'est un handicap donc
c'est ma deuxième ma deuxième précision
que je voudrais faire et la troisième
c'est que nous depuis le début des
auditions par rapport au prix outre que
nous demandons une transparence parce
que c'est une opacité terrible mais il
nous semble quand même important de
prendre en compte un certain nombre de
facteurs et que ça soit visible
c'est-à-dire ce que vous avez dit bon
c'est le service médical rendu ça c'est
voilà c'est mais ce sont les critères
environnementaux et et sociaux c'est le
coût de la production parce que on a vu
quand même notamment dans les mollycles
pour les médicaments innovants des prix
exorbitants
éthiquement absolument bon voilà je vais
juste dire exorbitant et
donc c'est pas possible alors que les
coûts de production étaient bien bien
plus petit et la troisième chose c'est
effectivement la marge
normale de de bénéfices que toute
entreprise doit faire on se sont les
critères à enfin qui nous semble
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
pour répondre à votre question
j'insisterai sur le fait que dans la
chaîne que vous évoquez il y a deux
métiers distincts il y a celui du
chimiste qui fait le principe actif et
celui du pharmacien qui fait la
préparation galénique ce qu'on appelle
trivialement le médicament donc et on a
de nombreuses exemples ou nous avons le
principe actif qui est fabriqué dans nos
usines et des ruptures sur la sur le
médicament proprement dit et ça c'est
une partie sur lequel le chimiste est
inopérant alors
on peut améliorer les les choses par par
décision je dirais régalienne et c'est
l'exemple que je citais tout à l'heure
de de Monsieur Jérôme Salomon sur le
sixatraquarium où là on a été capable à
partir d'un principe actif qui n'était
pas celui qui était dans le dossier du
pharmacien de le mettre sur le marché en
quelques semaines donc ça je pense que
c'est un exemple
creuser qui est la simplification
de
la mise sur le marché
d'un principe actif qui n'est pas celui
nécessairement dans le dossier tel que
déposé par le pharmacien mais qui
correspond à une usine qui est
parfaitement agréée par la NSM et qui
est un procédé qui est déjà reconnu par
d'autres clients qui ont des pharmaciens
responsables qui l'ont validé déjà pour
faire des préparations galéniques donc
ça c'est ça c'est probablement
une piste que nous pouvons
explorer en la matière alors donc c'est
vrai que c'est frustrant pour tout le
monde on a régulièrement des discussions
de constater que le principe actif est
là et que les préparations galéniques ne
sont pas dans les officines ou à la
pharmacie de l'hôpital donc là dessus là
et c'est malheureusement une discussion
tripartite j'y reviens qui est
absolument indispensable à mettre en
place
effectivement la discussion tripartite
s'impose sur le sur le paracétamol sur
cet exemple précis sans l'apport du PSA
et Sanofi la seule production de
principes actifs en France ne garantit
pas la disponibilité des spécialités et
ne garantit pas même la pérennité de
cette installation dans le temps donc ça
c'est vraiment important et vous parliez
également de qu'est-ce qui fait
aujourd'hui qu'on investit pas dans des
capacités ou qu'on a des capacités
sous-utilisées clairement la demande le
facteur prix et le facteur déterminant
donc si on n'a pas le niveau de
compétitivité qu'on couvre pas nos coûts
et comme vous l'avez dit une marge
raisonnable qui permet de rentabiliser
nos investissements et surtout de
continuer à investir dans notre outil de
production
on n'a pas de marché donc la question du
marché et de la demande de nos clients
est absolument essentielle d'où le
l'aspect de travail tripartite pour
s'assurer que le laboratoire
pharmaceutique ou son sous-traitant pour
la ganellik et le producteur de principe
actif travaille conjointement et dans
les projets sur lesquels travaillent le
gouvernement actuellement sur les msis
clairement ils vise à créer ces accords
tripartit et c'est là dessus qu'on
parviendra à solidifier les chaînes de
valeur enfin sur le prix et la
transparence enfin de notre côté on est
quand même sur des des métiers fortement
concurrentiels des métiers où les
niveaux de marge on n'a pas de on a de
la R&D à couvrir mais c'est sans commune
mesure avec la R&D sur les médicaments
innovants et quand un laboratoire
pharmaceutique vient nous confier la
production de de son principe actif sous
brevet par exemple puisque j'imagine que
votre question portait sur les
médicaments hors de prix sous brevet en
général on a plusieurs producteurs de
principes actifs on est en concurrence
et on est sur une base coup de
production plus marge donc deux notes de
vue vis-à-vis de nos clients on a pas
une transparence totale puisqu'il y a le
secret des affaires mais on est sur un
niveau de transparence assez importante
et je pense que sur la chaîne de valeur
quand on voit le prix il faut également
la sortir de certaines conditions on
parlait du CEPS tout à l'heure on a un
article qui permet de favoriser des
investissements dans notre pays que ce
soit pour les médicaments innovants ou
pour les médicaments futurs on pourrait
l'utiliser en contrepartie d'un partage
d'informations et en contrepartie d'une
sécurité d'approvisionnement et tous les
projets qui ont été soutenus par le
programme France relance avait ce type
de contrepartie
ce que je voulais dire également c'est
que vous nous parlez prudence de marché
effectivement nous comme vous le dites
nous avons des capacités de fabrication
qui peuvent être plus ou moins définie
sur chaque principe actif même si on
peut utiliser d'autres recettes on peut
très bien ce qu'on appelle des goulotter
nos productions et faire des volumes
plus importants en fait comme je le
disais dans mes propos liminaires on est
assez aveugle sur la demande c'est que
on a une demande
qui est bien identifié chez les clients
que nous avons identifié pour lequel
notre dossier est enregistré dans bien
des cas nous tapons aux portes de
certains de d'autres je dirais clients
pour que notre dossier soit enregistré
de façon à ce qu'il puisse
approvisionner mais c'est le bon vouloir
de nos clients de nous enregistrer ou
pas et
dans bien des cas nous sommes fabricants
mais nous ne vendons pas à des gens qui
sont pourtant des exploitants de ce type
de molécule donc oui il y a toujours
chez nous un tout petit peu de conduire
de prudence mais en règle générale c'est
parce que nous n'avons pas la
connaissance complète des volumes de
même si cuvia donne beaucoup
d'informations mais on a on n'a pas
forcément la connaissance complète des
de tout le marché aval des des qui
utilisaient principes actifs que nous
fabriquons
pour répondre à Madame la rapporteur sur
la sur la sur la transparence des prix
vous avez noté qu'on a accepté de vous
donner des éléments chiffrés très précis
sur le sur le cas de les oméprazols bon
bien évidemment on se met à risque parce
qu'on je vous ai communiqué une
information critique mais je pense que
pour le propos de la commission
c'était important d'avoir une idée
j'attire votre attention sur le fait et
je reviens sur mes chiffres que
ça tient à pas grand chose c'est-à-dire
que 1 à 2% de plus du prix de la boîte
avant en horaire de dispensation à un
effet majeur pour le chimiste
et ça c'est un peu je voudrais pas
rentrer dans la catégorie des paysans
qui se plaignent face au distributeur
c'est pas du tout le propos mais si on
veut une industrie du principe actif
souveraine en Europe en général et en
France en particulier
le coût est par exemple c'est ça que je
voulais passer aussi comme message
point auquel on a pas répondu c'est la
recette de production
donc comment on l'a dit il y a deux
métiers il y a le chimiste et le
pharmacien donc là on parle pour le
chimiste nous le seul point qu'on a
c'est qu'on est en général sur des
usines polyvalentes et de donc si on a
la capacité à produire avec l'ensemble
des certifications qui vont bien et un
minimum de volume qui permettent de
maintenir actif notre CEP en
l'occurrence on est capable ensuite de
moduler en fonction de la demande et de
répondre très rapidement s'il faut
développer en un temps record un procédé
de production de zéro
il faut de la recherche pour développer
le procédé de production et notre
concurrent va pas très gentiment nous le
donner sur un plateau et en plus même si
nous le donner sur un plateau il
faudrait qu'on l'adapte à nos capacités
de production qui sont pas strictement
les mêmes c'est pas strictement la même
taille de réacteur c'est pas les mêmes
équipements c'est pas les mêmes sources
d'énergie ou autre
donc la partie développement du procédé
le point là c'est plutôt il faut
anticiper c'est pas forcément une
question de transparence je pense que si
quelqu'un
vous lui dites développez moi cette
recette de production il faut juste
qu'il ait le temps de la mettre en place
le temps de la qualifier puisque on veut
pas faire n'importe quoi sinon il y a
des patients qui risquent d'en subir les
conséquences et l'anticipation que ce
soit sur la partie chimiste qui nous
concerne ou la partie galénique qui nous
concerne et qui est pas et qui concerne
nos clients on peut anticiper avoir les
recettes prêtes avoir des contrats que
ce soit nos clients avec les hôpitaux ou
nous avec nos clients pour être prêt en
cas de besoin à produire et c'est ça qui
manque plus que la transparence je pense
pas que la 3 la transparence soit un
sujet c'est si vous voulez développer un
procédé de zéro le paracétamol on l'a
fait on a un délire record on a on a mis
un an et demi de développement voilà si
vous voulez développer quelque chose
sans transfert technologique donc ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon intègre
transfert c'est minimum un an un an et
demi de labo pour s'assurer qu'on arrive
à la fin à la qualité du produit voulu
parce que je pense que tout le monde
veut la qualité requise et j'ajouterai à
ce point là donc vous parliez
effectivement de recettes top secret
elles sont pas top secret vous les avez
dans dans tout DMF et CEP comme le
préciser Frédéric vous avez les procédés
de fabrication qui sont enregistrés
après il s'agit donc en dehors de de de
toute recherche et développement de
faire un transfert technique comme on le
fait parfois pour d'un site sur un autre
c'est quand même long ça nécessite quand
même un certain investissement parce que
vous vous êtes obligé de développer sur
un autre site de fabrication une recette
ça prend un petit peu de temps parce
qu'il faut qualifier requalifier la
production requalifier le matériel etc
donc vous en avez pour un an ou deux ans
si on suit absolument
tous les tous les principes mais faire
un tec transfert quand on a le procédé
et qu'on veut le faire à l'identique
c'est pas quelque chose c'est quelque
chose qu'on a l'habitude de faire
fréquemment ce que disait Gildas ou ce
que disait Frédéric c'est que dans bien
des cas
on a constaté que la plupart des
fabrications avaient été fait en Europe
ensuite elles ont été transférées en
Asie en Asie elle c'est toujours des
procédés plutôt anciens qui sont
utilisés
l'opportunité qu'a l'Europe actuellement
c'est de reprendre tous ces procédés d'y
mettre de la floquer Mesrine la catalyse
enzymatique des choses un petit peu plus
modernes et de réintégrer donc des
fabrications qui sont plus vertes qui
sont plus économiques et avec des
procédés de fabrication qui sont
plus innovants et c'est vraiment ce à
quoi notre industrie voilà ce ce
mobilise pour l'instant reste à savoir
sur quelle molécule on doit faire ça
nous on le fait sur un certain nombre de
molécules que l'on connaît mais si on
définit une liste de molécules il y a
peut-être des choses à faire dans ces
domaines là
je vais juste mais on pourrait encore
passer beaucoup de questions mais là le
temps va être contraint mais est-ce que
vous êtes en relation avec Emma et
est-ce que vous pensez que la question
de l'agenda stratégique de consolidation
de fabrication des principes actifs au
niveau européen et quelque chose qui est
en marche en route ou est-ce que il va
se passer un petit peu de temps avant
qu'on puisse envisager ne serait-ce que
l'écriture de la première ligne ça c'est
ma première question et puis la deuxième
vous n'avez pas répondu à cette question
des appels d'offres hospitalier parce
qu'en fait la masse critique de commande
elle vient elle vient de ses appels
d'offres et j'ajouterai les appels
d'offres pour les cliniques privées
désormais parce que ce sont des groupes
qui et qui sont ils deviennent donc des
interlocuteurs importants dans dans la
consolidation des des commandes et du
modèle économique
c'est quoi la condition du
made in France ou du made in Europe
est-ce que c'est l'API est-ce que c'est
un pays façonnier etc etc c'est quoi la
comment on fait parce que corticoïdes
par exemple quand il costéoïde voilà on
a un exemple qui est qui est flagrant
c'est pas parce que c'est fabriqué en
France que derrière
derrière on a suffisamment de produit
donc c'est un vrai sujet parce que on
nous parle à chaque fois de de cette
condition du fabriquer
en proximité enfin le plus en proximité
possible et finalement derrière la
chaîne de valeur du médicament étant
tellement complexe on se dit quelque
part que ce qu'il faut que ce soit un
des éléments de la chaîne qui
garantissent des choses
pour répondre à cette à ce point dans le
la proposition qu'on avait faite il y a
cinq six ans on voulait on avait imaginé
une petite fleur avec trois pétales
l'une qui correspondait aux principes
actif et qui donnait l'origine principe
actif une deuxième qui correspondait à
où se trouvait la galénique et une
troisième dans le cas de par exemple de
produits injectables d'où venait les
dispositifs médicaux etc et donc on
avait imaginé ce petit dispositif là qui
permettait de donner une indication sur
voilà où était fait le principe actif et
encore une fois c'est des fois
insuffisant parce qu'il faudrait
regarder où sont toutes les matières
premières sont faites mais c'était déjà
un propriétaire où est d'où venait la
seringue ou le dispositif médical
important et d'où était fait la
galinique voilà c'était un point pour
répondre à votre deuxième question nous
on nous sommes peu en contact avec les
mains
nous répondons peu directement aux
appels d'offres hospitalier je vais
passer peut-être la parole à
Gildas pour la partie européenne et
l'agenda européen sachez que on y
participe que la France est très en
vraiment très poussé énormément que nous
en tant que psycho sont poussés
énormément aussi on est vraiment voilà
je pense qu'on a un effet sur le FCG et
ses filles qu'on pousse beaucoup la
France pousse beaucoup au niveau
européen et égides peut peut-être vous
parler des d'où on en est des travaux
européens pour l'actuel actuellement
clairement vous savez que la législation
pharmaceutique européenne et en cours de
révision un premier draft a été sorti je
crois que c'est fin mars il y a très peu
de choses sur la pénurie il y a un non
paper comme on les appelle au niveau
européen qui a été publié par 19 États
membres et je crois que deux ou trois
autres ont rejoint donc on doit être à
21 22 États membres sur 27 donc
pratiquement tous les États qui
demandent à la Commission de travailler
sur un critique un critical medicine Act
donc nous c'est quelque chose qu'on
appelle de nos vœux depuis 2019 à savoir
que de la même façon qu'on a un tips
actes qu'on a un critical rematériel
actes qu'on a des secteurs stratégiques
qui font l'objet
d'une d'une d'un rapport spécifique
visant à d'abord regarder quels sont les
besoins de l'Europe en termes de
principes actifs critiques ou de
médicaments critiques je pense que c'est
un premier point sur lequel ils vont il
faut se poser ça passe par quelle liste
de médicaments sont considérées comme
critiques qu'est-ce qu'on veut en Europe
est-ce qu'on veut des critères
environnementaux et sociaux à ce
niveau-là ou est-ce qu'on veut une
sécurité de d'approvisionnement absolu
est-ce qu'on veut une diversité des
sources donc d'abord c'est ce qu'on veut
ensuite je pense et c'est très important
et Vincent l'a rappelé c'est faire
l'inventaire
de ce qu'il y a puisque on sait ce qu'on
veut qu'est-ce qu'il y a et aujourd'hui
tout est en papier on voit que les mains
a du mal à rentrer dans le sujet de
faire l'inventaire des capacités de
production sur le principe actif sur la
galénique sur les dispositifs médicaux
or elle a toutes les informations
puisque notre industrie est quand même
celle qui est la plus contrôlée
du monde enfin en Europe en tout cas
c'est une des industries les plus
contrôlées elle a la possibilité d'avoir
ces informations et de faire
un mapping des capacités existantes et
ensuite si les capacités existantes ne
répondent pas à ce que politiquement
l'Europe à ce don politiquement l'Europe
souhaite se doter mais dans ce cas-là
des mesures adaptées pour combler le
différentiel entre ce dont on a besoin
et ce dont on dispose
le problème se critical médicinal tout
le monde le veut nous ça fait depuis
2019 qu'on le demande on a un certain
momentum sur le sujet il reste plus
qu'un an à la Commission européenne donc
soit elle se met au travail avant l'été
soit en attendant la prochaine
commission enfin pour être tout à fait
honnête donc aimer elle a toutes les
infos enfin c'est maximum 6 mois de
travail c'est juste il faut qu'elle
considère ce sujet comme important elle
l'avait considéré comme important à deux
moments en novembre 2020 lors de la
publication de la stratégie
pharmaceutique européenne où elle
montrait l'évidence de de couper la
dépendance de l'Europe aux autres
régions du monde pour la production
principale actif et ensuite elle a
renouvelé en mai 2021 en considérant la
production principale
stratégiques de l'Europe il y en avait
pas 150 000 il y en avait 6 parmi
lesquels les batteries l'hydrogène les
les chips et les principes actifs
y compris les matières premières
critiques etc et dans tous les autres il
y a eu un acte et il y a que les
principes actifs qui ont été orphelins
de cet acte alors que c'est un quelque
chose de particulièrement important donc
il est encore temps de faire quelque
chose mais il faut qu'il se mette vite
au travail
pour finir de répondre à vos questions
madame la Présidente sur les aspects
comment faire d'un point de vue pratique
je me permets de revenir sur sur ce
point là
encore une fois si vous voulez dire en
France ça me paraît exclu vu les lois
européennes mais dans l'Union européenne
si vous voulez dire que le
médicament a été fabriqué dans l'Union
européenne pour la partie chimie vous
pouvez prendre ce qui est enregistré
dans le DMF ou le CEP et là c'est
transparent les agences le savent
puisque les usines doivent être
identifiées et enregistrées donc vous
savez si elles sont sur le territoire
européen ou pas la galénique c'est la
même chose puisqu'il y a une unité en
général de lieu pour l'étape galénique
avec une seule usine non la plupart des
cas donc là pareil l'usine est sur le
territoire européen ou elle ne le l'est
pas sur les dispositifs médicaux c'est
peut-être un petit peu plus compliqué
mais au moins sur l'essentiel
du marché là vous avez un point pratique
pour savoir si c'est fabriqué en Europe
ou pas et vous pouvez mettre une
barrière
à périmètre que personne ne vous
contestera qui est celui du dossier
d'enregistrement alors sur les appels
d'offres on n'a pas répondu à cette
question qui a un peu technique il y a
aujourd'hui il y a aujourd'hui deux
écueils nous sommes fabricants de
principes actifs pharmaceutique nous
sommes pas fabricants de médicaments
donc pour que ce que vous dites puisse
exister il y a deux choses qu'il faut
faire d'abord il faudrait généraliser
les préparations magistrates c'est ce
que vous avez vu sur l'amoxicilline
c'est-à-dire que d'une manière étendue
des pharmaciens et en l'occurrence par
exemple les pharmacies hospitalières
pourraient acheter les principes actifs
et faire les préparations magistrales
donc ça ce serait possible moyennant des
investissements colossaux
voilà faut être réaliste et la deuxième
chose ne perdez pas de vue que un
médicament n'arrive pas en officine
comme ça il y a ce qu'on appelle un
pharmacien responsable qui engage son
nom sur la qualité du médicament et ça
c'est spécifique à la partie
galénique c'est très rare que l'usine de
fabrication du principe actif et un
statut d'établissement pharmaceutique
nous sommes largement encadrés et
contrôlé mais nous ne sommes pas
pharmacien responsable donc c'est pour
ça que nous répondons pas aux appels
d'offres
la question c'était quand on rédige un
appel d'offres
en référence voilà une fabrication
plutôt en circuit secours ou semi-court
on était des choses comme ça
évidemment vous ne contractez vous ne
participez pas à la contractualisation
mais il y a une façon de rédiger l'appel
d'offres qui permet de ne pas oublier un
des éléments de la chaîne de valeur et
quand on parle des API il y a quand même
les matières premières les matières
premières aussi je veux dire si on
pousse à l'extrême la chaîne de valeur
il y a les solvants il y a tout tout les
les éléments essentiels qui certes à
fabriquer l'API ou l'exception du reste
et là pour le coup est-ce qu'on
introduit ces questions là on voit bien
que c'est un peu vertigineux contenu de
la complexité de la chaîne du médicament
il y a un chiffre ok si vous permettez
madame présidente qu'on vous a pas donné
mais qui a été maintenant assez
correctement à étudier qui a été pris en
compte par la par la DGE c'est que pour
garder la chaîne du médicament
entre
83 et 86% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre sont dans la partie fabrication
du principe actif donc si vous rentrez
une notion territoriale on va se heurter
aux règles de l'OMS si vous dites les
DMF doit correspondre à des fabrications
sur le sol européen c'est compliqué en
revanche contenu du poids RSE colossal
du principe actif je rappelle en moyenne
85%, ça c'est un critère que vous pouvez
imposer et qui est logique à la fois
avec la politique de la France et la
politique européenne et qui est un
avantage d'ailleurs
que je vous remercie beaucoup à moi de
vous souhaitiez intervenir avant la fin
de cette audition
et bien je vous en prie puisque je
conclurai moi-même d'accord donc non non
je voulais simplement rappeler les
messages clés du cycos en termes de
conclusion vous dire que la
réindustrialisation elle doit se faire
on y est vraiment très favorable mais
elle ne pourra se faire que sur un
périmètre défini il faut bien faire
attention de bien définir le périmètre à
sécuriser
et surtout la filière qu'il nous faut
une symétrie des politiques publiques
sécurisée bien sûr l'offre industrielle
on a et beaucoup pété aidé par les les
gouvernements dans ce domaine là mais
que la demande doit être sécurisée aussi
en parallèle c'est extrêmement important
pour nous puisque ça donne de la
pérennité de la vision que la prise en
charge des critères environnementaux et
sociaux pour nous et essentiel qu'elle
fait partie de la constitution de notre
prix et qu'elle n'est pas pour autant
suffisamment reconnue dans le danger
dans l'établissement des prix et que le
dernier point c'est qu'il ne faut pas
oublier la dimension européenne
toutes les critiques et que on ne fera
rien toutes les solutions ne peuvent se
gérer qu'au niveau européen
bien reçu merci beaucoup pour pour ces
messages de ce message de conclusion
qui sont pas tout à fait en
contradiction avec toutes les auditions
que nous avons eu précédemment et l'idée
qu'on se fait de cette commission
duncaire dans lequel je vous remercie
aussi beaucoup de la qualité de vos
réponses peut-être
aurez-vous à compléter si besoin par
écrit sur quelques questions
particulières nous allons nous allons
travailler entre nous pour vous proposer
cela et je vous remercie beaucoup et je
dis à mes collègues qu'on se retrouve
dans l'après-midi pour d'autres
auditions
je vous remercie